Listen, let's not mince words. Elizabeth Warren
has a totally toxic surrogate with racist
and homophobic tweets in her past. I'm going
to talk about this right now. I'm going to
give you the full story, but before I get
into that
several dozen of you beautifully nice people
emailed me about this over the last 24 hours.
The gist of the emails was, David, you covered
Bernie's toxic surrogate. Linda Sarsour but
you won't cover Elizabeth Warren's equally
toxic surrogate because you're a Warren shill
or an establishment centrist or a Warren tool
or whatever. No, no, no, no, no. I covered
Linda Sarsour because she is a toxic person
and no democratic candidate should have someone
like her as a surrogate, which Bernie does.
My coverage was not partisan. It was not for
or against any candidate. I want my house
clean no matter who we're what we are talking
about. In the same way, I'd be a hypocrite
if I didn't cover a toxic Warren surrogate.
We need, our conscience is clean. We need
to clean our houses. So today I'm going to
tell you about Ashley Marie. Preston. Preston
is a Warren campaign surrogate.
She has appeared on many shows as a surrogate,
including over a with our friends at the young
Turks. She's in a Warren campaign ad that
was released, uh, five or six days ago and
Preston has a disgusting Twitter history of
racism and homophobia, period. I am not going
to mitigate it in any way. Some items from
her past quotes, Latino and Asian businesses
need to stop being rude and effing disrespectful.
And I know it's a lot to ask, but in California,
speak effing English. This is the type of
thing we hear all the time from the disgusting
people on the right and we denounce it and
we have to denounce it here. The identity
of Ashley Marie Preston is not a mitigating
factor in that this is absolutely disgusting,
depraved speech. Another example from a Warren
surrogate, Ashley Marie Preston quote, I love
gay men, but this County clerk at window G
is an M effing fag.
It I could go on, but I won't. Now there are
some in the identity politics sliver of the
left who have come to defend Ashley Marie
Preston on the basis of different identity
boxes that she checks. For example, Preston
is transgender and thus we need to understand
something about her treatment by society about
her experience that makes this somehow more
okay or not as bad or as a black person. Preston
has been, uh, treated so poorly by the way,
that society, no guys, no. Okay, we can't
defend this. She has no place in any democratic
campaign, no matter what her identity is.
Now there are people choosing to make the
story about TYT. I believe T Y T has put out
a statement. The bottom line is that from
what I've seen of this, uh, surrogates appearances
on TYT TYT identified Preston as a Warren
surrogate when she would comment, I don't
know much else about what TYT should be doing
in terms of checking the Twitter histories
of everyone.
My guess is Preston maybe is not going to
be back on TYT but I could be wrong. But the
important thing is that if the argument is
TYT was wrong to have her on, I would want
to understand why. Because people associated
with campaigns do shows all the time. And
as far as I know, she was identified as a
surrogate. If the argument is T Y T was short
sighted because they didn't do their due diligence
about the things in Ashley Marie Preston's
past. Okay. But then the campaign who had
her as a surrogate, uh, is 10 times more wrong
for not doing their due diligence. Since then.
She's actually a surrogate of the campaign.
She's just appearing on TYT. But the bottom
line is I'm not a hypocrite. Linda Sarsour
is toxic and Bernie should have no affiliation
with her. Ashley Marie Preston is toxic and
Warren should have no affiliation with her.
There's no place for this. Okay. I got a few
emails from Warren supporters saying, David,
I think this is horrible. I'm contacting the
Warren campaign and saying, Preston must be
removed as a surrogate. Great. I'm an equal
opportunity person on this. I'm not affiliated
with any campaign. Bernie should get rid of
Linda Sarsour as a surrogate. Warren should
get rid of Ashley Marie Preston as a surrogate.
We shouldn't even be wasting time arguing
about this. This is 100% cut and dry. There
are too many problems that need to be solved.
There are too many issues that need to be
discussed. We need to sort out how does Bernie's,
uh, health care policy compared to that of
Elizabeth Warren? What will each cost, how
will each be implemented? What we'll each
cover? But all of this stuff, right? We can't
be distracted with toxic surrogates. With
absolutely vile, disgusting, homophobic, and
racist comments in their Twitter histories.
This is a disservice to Elizabeth Warren,
Linda Sarsour. It does a disservice to Bernie
Sanders. They should be gone and we should
be focusing on the issues period. And for
everybody who said, I wouldn't talk about
this because I'm some kind of Warren shill,
uh, I think I'm being a pretty unequivocal
in my comments here today.